a decade ago a company joined TechStars
incubator in Boulder Colorado and that
company was Sen grid and they went
public the first incubator company to
ever go public came out of tech stars
you might think Y Combinator or 500
sharps nope came out of tech stars and
that company was recently acquired by
Twilio another amazing company and to
talk about the amazing growth that Sen
grid has had and this journey from
growth all the way to acquisition is
Samir Dholakia did I get it right
perfect perfect
yes slam-dunking dokie good Samir
Dholakia who is the CEO and you you
joined what your four or five of the
company that's right yeah five years in
five years in no and this is sometimes
like a controversial topic yeah bringing
in a professional CEO how did that all
go down was it out of some weakness the
company was not being managed properly
or opportunistic they wanted to deal
with the scaling and they did a proper
search etc how did you come about that
you got drawn into this yeah I think I
I was the second actually professional
CEO brought in Wow
so I so the the founding story three
developers awesome amazing guys
Isaac Tim and Jose kick this thing off a
no.9 as you said through techstars and
they just had this insight that every
time you build an application when you
click on the forgot password button it
has to there has to be code that sits
behind it that sends you an automated
email that allows you to go and reset it
or if you click the Buy button same
thing like an automated email comes in
no human and setting up the code to do
that was crazy complicated they're like
this shouldn't be that complicated every
application on the planet every website
on the planet has to do this let's make
something easy put in the cloud and off
they go so they literally come out of
the tech stars they graduate from tech
stars at the end of the program and
everyone in the program is using it and
right it's immediate like they go yeah
the the acceleration of the business was
media about two years in maybe not even
that about eighteen two months and two
years in they they got their series a
and and we're asked you know hey gents
you know we'd love to bring in a
professional CEO
they can continue to help scale this
thing because it's clearly gonna be a
rocket ship right so that's when my
predecessor came in a guy named Jim
Franklin great guy who's did amazing
work for the business for which we're
all very grateful and and then I joined
I only lasted two years so it could have
been a cry no actually I look back I
think he was there for a good three and
a half almost okay three and half four
years all right so he did and he did a
great job he took it from two million in
revenue probably to about thirty oh that
would be pretty good yeah and he did a
great job over that period of time the
thing that I said double double double
right two to four to eight it's probably
ThinkCentre than that I think it was
more like the I think that they tripled
I think it was triple triple double
double I'm thinking those in the round
years there's a great credit absolutely
and and and I'm really great the thing
I'm most grateful to Jim for is the the
culture that he embedded in the company
at that early stage and we care a ton
about culture and and people and values
and how we do our work matters as much
as what we're doing and I think he did a
tremendous job he brought this this
notion of what we call the four H's
happy hungry humble and honest it's very
simple easy to remember you know that's
that those and that became the culture
that became like your values I guess
that's right did you before you came
there did you think values was like a
soft kind of you know wishy-washy
feel-good hippie dippie that kind of
thing did you actually believe in
culture back then ten years ago you know
even then I would say I would say ten or
fifteen years ago I was probably more on
the okay you know that's all fine and
good if you don't have a great business
you're in trouble what you still think
is true but by the time I got to that
stage of my career when I was looking
for my next thing on my criteria list of
the opportunity I wanted to find next
culture was near the top of the list I
really cared a lot well defined culture
for people who are founders and let's
say they're not a thirty million yet but
they're building towards that and how
should they think about culture because
it's a word that's kind of loaded right
like culture the the culture what
culture you know
yeah what does it mean practically you
know I we talk a lot about it as who we
are are the kind of the values that we
exhibit right but the the culture to me
is sort of the sum of every interaction
that happens among our teammates and our
customers our partners in every hallway
conversation and every meeting room
every negotiation we do that to me it's
how we show up in those moments define
your culture and it's their guardrails
that you want to set up around that of
like this is how we want to show up this
is how we want to work with each other
and I'll tell you I think that having a
constant set of reinforcements of this
is how we want to do it is really
important and I would say you know all
the founders and CEOs out there building
companies institutionalizing those
values is the only way to actually make
those things real because otherwise
they're they're really just you know the
the posters on the wall in the cafeteria
yeah
like motivational posters that are
really just contrived and yeah but you
know what what I see to dismiss
absolutely right is you you'll walk
you'll start walking past them and
you'll never notice them again but look
an iceberg right it are well ofin you
know I think it's really important that
that you embed them into your actual
activity stated how do you do that no
you said one humble and then what was
the other one hustle happy happy I'll be
right hungry okay that's down bull and
honest so how do you get hungry what was
it wait happy happy we got okay hungry
hungry that's what I'm interested in
hungry hungry humble how do you get
those two two hungry and humble yeah
give me an example of how you make sure
everybody's hungry and humble
concurrently cuz you seem like cool and
they are and that's actually one of the
beauties is sometimes you want some
tension between the two but yeah part of
the thing that yeah that we found we had
to do as an example if you really care
about culture the people coming in the
door the people you are hiring if you're
you know if you're in a start-up the
person you make an offer to next is
probably the most important decision you
made as a business that week and so what
we did is said okay we care a lot about
values we care a lot
recruiting and the talent we're bringing
aboard to take that take the hill with
us so we literally took each of the four
H's Rhoda down a set of questions that
we believed would help us elicit whether
or not we thought that person aligned
with worldview so you you created a
questionnaire yeah that your
interviewers will do that align with the
values exactly I could give you an
example like for the humble do they know
that there when those questions are
being asked that they're aligned there
is that like just a little internal link
all the interviewers name yeah the
interviewees do not or not so they're
just answering questions answering
questions so like as an example we would
have one for the humble age that would
be you know Jason tell us a little bit
about the professional accomplishment
you are most proud of I'm the greatest
angel investor of all time everybody
else a second to me and you would maybe
not pass that exactly that's why I was
immature no but but what we would do is
we would ask that question and then
literally the interviewer would sit back
and just do a pronoun count hmm how many
times did the interview we use the
pronoun I versus we grin that would
usually tell us everything we needed to
know about whether or not they were
gonna fit in I have hit seven unicorns I
have done exactly right there is no way
Joey and tea so that's fascinating the
way in you have to operationalize when
you fire people and you dismiss them and
you terminate them are you like pointing
to the like you're not humble or okay
that point it's just that that's so it's
over by that point we try to love people
out with grace you know is love people
out with grace unpack that yeah I
believe that at the end of the day if
for whatever reason things don't work
out between a company and a teammate it
is going to be probably one of the worst
days and that person's life and career
mhm mhm and there's just there that is
not the time to be delivering hard and
even if it's constructive feedback that
we should have done months and months
prior to that moment right and if we
didn't do that shame on us
but at that moment that is not the time
to start it's a time for love love and
grace and you should embrace then grace
means like you know are we going to
explain to
the entire team why so-and-so left the
company we are not we are going whatever
reason that person wants to ascribe to
their departure will be what we talk
about broadly because I know why they
owe them grace now we now I know why
they gave you the reins of a thirty
million dollar company
you're a considered thoughtful person
this is what we try to run anything
because I would be like oh you're fired
let me explain oh it's staff lunch let
all the reasons this person screwed up
no I it is it is so tempting on the way
out to want to help the person it is
yeah
by telling him exactly how underwhelming
their performance was yeah but it's not
but that's just not the time it's you
know that I had a great mentor of mine
I've been so lucky to have many over the
course of my career and one of them said
in the making that decision you need to
be spock-like in the decision and mother
Teresa like in the delivery oh that's
and that's and it's just a very simple
and when you think about it that way
you're like you're right you have to be
dispassionate in making the call because
it's hard and you just got to be
objective and is can I put somebody in
that seat who is going to be better and
able to help our company succeed and
live up to our full potential the answer
is yes you need to be spock-like in that
decision yeah when you have that
communication or conversation with your
teammate you got to be mother Teresa
like because that's gonna be the worst
news they've heard in a long time all
right when we get back I want to know
how you grew from 330 million when you
took over or so - at the exit - Twilio
what was the revenue in the final
quarter or the year 2018 revenue was out
already or now what's your last public
I'm talking of our last public I think
we were probably the last public was
probably north of 150 million dollar run
rate would be the 150 per quarter per
year per quarter sorry per annualize for
you know so for the year take Q three
times 5x did ya a lot right amazing when
we get back more wisdom from Samir on
this week in startups
[Music]